[Music]
the year was
[Music]
1975. it was a warm june evening in
south carolina and 14 year old jason
white was ready to prove his medal like
a lot of boys his age it mattered a
great deal to him that his peers saw him
as strong tough and most importantly of
all brave that's why he was camped out
alone just outside of the junkyard as
the sky went dark above him he had heard
rumors about the things that went on
inside the junkyard scary things
unnatural things but jason wasn't about
to let those stories scare him he knew
for a fact that the junkyard had been
abandoned for months if not longer
nobody was in there he'd be fine or at
least that's what he kept telling
himself with the moon high up in the sky
jason crept into the junkyard using a
flashlight's beam to light his way
behind the towers of busted down cars
and scrap metal he heard a distant but
loud grinding noise
was it coming from one of the warehouses
no that's impossible he thought just his
mind playing tricks on him but curiosity
compelled him to get closer jason
approached the warehouse and saw that
the big iron door was still a jar his
heart was in his throat as he peered
into the building and saw the impossible
it was a man no a machine cobbled
together from pipes wires and aluminum
it was using a power saw to cut apart
metal on a workbench but it wasn't just
one robot there was movement all around
it jerking and twitching in the shadows
as his flashlight beam passed over them
jason saw the moving living bodies of a
menagerie of metal creatures he screamed
in shock and the robotic denizens of the
warehouse all turned and looked at him
jason had never felt more afraid in his
life until the humanoid robots still
carrying the power saw turn and began
walking towards him it was waving his
free hand around wildly in what jason
perceived as some kind of threat letting
out another animal screech jason turned
and ran all the way out of the junkyard
until the sounds of clanking metal faded
out behind him jason was scarred for
life and in that moment he vowed never
to return to his local junkyard ever
again and this was a wise choice because
not long after that a very different
group would be commandeering the
junkyard and as fans of this channel
will know they don't take kindly to
intruders if you've ever been on a long
road trip through a rural part of the
united states you've most likely seen a
few quirky signs and wacky looking
businesses along the way whether it's a
diner with a dinosaur protruding out of
the front a gas station shaped like a
ufo or a particularly weird mural
businesses in the small towns lining the
freeways often have to get creative when
it comes to attracting patrons locations
like this saw their heyday in the 1950s
and 1960s but as the cost of gasoline
skyrocketed in the 70s and technological
advances in aviation made flights more
accessible as a form of travel less and
less people were making long
cross-country drives on a regular basis
this caused an economic downturn in many
small towns and led to a large number of
quirky and unique roadside locations
being abandoned by their owners some
have been torn down or remodeled but
others remain as they were hanging on as
tourist destinations and serving as
reminders of a bygone era one such place
that you might encounter if you ever
find yourself heading down i-95 south is
jamaica joe's junkyard jubilee the
colorful storefront is decorated with a
mural depicting a picturesque tropical
lagoon while a sign reads one love in
hand-painted green and yellow letters at
first glance this might just seem like
another roadside oddity but if you were
to try and check it out you'd be blocked
by a patrol of six armed guards scp
foundation agents of course and
depending on how much you saw you might
be administered an amnesic before being
sent on your way because jamaica joe's
isn't just another junkyard it's scp-100
scp-100 came to the foundation's
attention on november 9 1976 after
tracking a series of rumors about a
mysterious abandoned scrapyard where the
machines ran on their own and strange
metal figures could be seen patrolling
the grounds when the foundation arrived
at the site they installed wooden
privacy screens around the fence of the
junkyard replaced the storefront windows
with one-way glass and redirected the
highway through a nearby town to keep
civilian traffic from getting too close
jamaican joe's junkyard jubilee is 5 000
square meters of fenced off land located
in rural south carolina as the name
suggests it's a junkyard made up of two
warehouses a storefront a small
residential building and a storage space
containing roughly 1500 vehicles of
varying makes and models some of which
have been compressed into cubes there is
also a variety of other metal scrap on
the site altogether valued to be worth
about five thousand dollars pocket
change to an organization like the scp
foundation just like many other cases
where the anomaly cannot be relocated to
a pre-established foundation containment
site for research the scp foundation
instead brought the research to the
anomaly the larger of the two warehouses
on site is now the de facto research
center for all matters involving scp-100
as well as a temporary residence for
on-site staff it is important to note
that there is nothing anomalous about
the location itself but within the area
of the junkyard are a variety of
euclid-class anomalous entities the
property was at one point owned by a man
by the name of joseph duvall presumably
the titular jamaican joe however the
whereabouts of mr duvall are unknown
research into local records show that
the utility bills to mr duvall's
personal address had stopped around
three months before the junkyard was
found upon the first sweep of the
location the foundation found no
evidence of human habitation
save for one note taped to the door of
the storefront reading out to lunch
please see assistant jj the first
anomaly that was cataloged on the site
was scp-100-1
a humanoid automaton made of scrap metal
mainly copper wires and tin cans
scp-100-1 has a limited degree of
sapience and although it has no means of
verbal or written communication it does
speak through the use of rudimentary
sign language it seems uninterested in
conversation though unless the topic has
to do with the sale of scrap metal the
information the foundation has been able
to learn from
scp-100-1 has been limited but the fact
it appears to be mostly work and very
little play is incredibly clear what it
lacks in conversational skills it makes
up for in craftsmanship scp-100-1
has been shown to be very adept at using
an arc welder drill power saw and other
machinery found around the junkyard
through its metalworking skills it is
able to create more beings like itself
from the scrap that surrounds it when
given the chance
scp-100-1 usually creates automatons
that resemble one of four animal species
flamingo crocodile turtle or iguana
however it's also able to create metal
copies of other creatures from bugs to
domestic pet breeds like cats and dogs
while the foundation usually destroys
the new constructs created by scp-100-1
it has been allowed to keep two in order
to keep it placid and preserve a cordial
working relationship with the foundation
operatives on site these two metal
creatures which both resemble large
metal insects have been designated as cp
100-2-a
and
scp-100-2-b though it seems
scp-100-1 has named them raymone and
beatrice respectively based on the fact
that those names are welded into the
backs of the creatures raymond a and
beatrice fulfill the role of perimeter
guards as well as companions to
scp-100-1
scp-100-1 and its pets are peaceful in
nature and in fact if they ever breach
the perimeter of the junkyard they lose
all autonomy seeming to shut down until
they are brought back within the
perimeter as such containment breaches
are nearly all to come from outsiders
trying to infiltrate the building rather
than any of the anomalies escaping
scp-100-1's main function seems to be
running the junkyard in the absence of
the mysterious jamaican joe duvall it
spends most of its days sorting scrap
metal building new constructs and
performing maintenance tasks around the
yard and the robot seems to follow a
very strict ritualistic schedule from
8am to 3pm scp-100-1
enters the storefront area of the
junkyard when a customer enters the shop
scp-100-1 will take its position behind
the front desk and begin bargaining with
them using hand gestures to convey
meaning
scp-100-1 possesses the ability to
perform the basic mental arithmetic
required to keep track of sales despite
seemingly being unable to read when
scp-100-1 has been observed making sales
to customers the foundation has found
that the robot can be very underhanded
and unfair when it comes to running its
business like a kind of metallic mr
krabs frequently it has been seen
intentionally selecting low quality
scrap or using scales that it knows are
faulty in order to scam customers it
also sells the animal automatons that it
creates knowing full well that they will
stop working as soon as they're taken
out of the junkyard in cases where
customers have rightfully come back to
demand refunds
scp-100-1 invariably responds by
gesturing to a sign on the wall which
reads no refunds mom written in a
phonetic jamaican accent after clocking
out for the day at 3 p.m
scp-100-1 spends an hour maintaining and
socializing with raymoney and beatrice
it's two insect-like pets it will also
communicate with them through hand
gestures and will engage them in games
of fetch or hide and seek in the
junkyard from 4pm until 8pm
scp-100-1 spends its time taking stock
and cleaning all the tools and machinery
on the premises it also takes time to
clean both the interiors and exteriors
of the various buildings on the site
then at 8 pm it appears to wind down for
the day with some leisure activities
including making more constructs playing
some more with its pets and taking
strolls around the perimeter of the site
this leisure time lasts until midnight
when
scp-100-1 will retire to the residential
part of the junkyard the robot doesn't
need to sleep but it does seem to rest
sitting motionless at a desk from
midnight until 8 am when it resumes the
schedule again from the beginning this
was all that was observed at scp-100 for
decades following its discovery
scp-100-1 was seemingly content with its
life and with the tasks that came with
running the junkyard however on june 3rd
2005
scp-100-1 did something it had never
done before as mentioned
scp-100-1 had only been seen using its
skills to create autonomous animals from
scrap metal but on june 3rd it chose to
create something else another humanoid
the automaton was only 10 centimeters
tall but
scp-100-1 took great care in crafting it
much more so than any of its creations
it gave the small figure distinct facial
features and made the whole thing from
high quality stainless steel when
scp-100-1 was finished with its creation
it welded the letters jj onto the back
and took it into the storefront during
its 8am to 3pm shift that day
scp-100-1 sat at the desk with jj on the
desk next to itself and the two seemed
to carry on a conversation through
signing and gestures as was policy with
all of
scp-100-1's constructs excluding
raymoney and beatrice jj was confiscated
which
scp-100-1 took very badly following jj's
removal
scp-100-1 returned to the residential
building and stayed there remaining a
nerd for a total of 10 days it is unsure
what really happened to the original
jamaican joe or what his precise
relationship was with scp-100-1
given the difficulty in communicating
with scp-100-1
it is possible that we'll never know for
sure but from what little we're able to
glean from the enigmatic out to lunch
please see assistant jj note he left
behind it's very possible that before he
left jamaica and joe may have created
the best assistant a junkyard owner
could possibly ask for now go check out
scp-5049 the skin salesman demon dan's
discount homunculus depot and scp-3008
trapped in ikea for more supernatural
enterprises from scp explained